bienvenido a la presentación de
derivadas creo que aquí es en donde uno
encuentra matemáticas mucho más
divertidas que hace algunos temas atrás
así que bueno vamos a empezar con
derivadas yo sé que que puede sonar muy
complicado pero bueno en general vamos a
empezar digamos que si yo tengo una
línea recta voy a pintar primero mis
ejes
y tengo aquí mis ejes coordenadas bueno
un intento de ejes coordenadas y si yo
tengo una línea recta digamos esta línea
hagan uso de toda su imaginación para
que crean que esto es una línea muy
recta pero bueno si yo tengo esta línea
recta y te pido hallar la tangente el
perdón la pendiente la pendiente de esta
línea simplemente necesitamos tomarnos
dos puntos cualesquiera sobre la línea
verdad entonces nos fijamos en este
punto ya sabemos que en realidad una
línea tiene la misma pendiente a lo
largo de toda ella verdad entonces nos
tomamos estos dos puntos y vamos a
extenderlo un poquito para que se vea
bien que nos tomamos dos puntos sobre la
línea y entonces sabemos que la
pendiente la pendiente la pendiente de
esta línea es igual al cambio en cambio
en g
cambio sobre el cambio en x sobre el
cambio en xy que estamos pensando en
realidad este es nuestro cambio en x que
lo denotamos como delta x y este es
nuestro cambio en g
este es nuestro camión ya que tanto
cambio la altura y que tanto cambio
digamos la en la parte horizontal
entonces esto lo podemos escribir como
detalle es una del delta que es una
letra griega sobre delta xy que éstas
representan cambio en jay cambio en x
muy bien entonces eso para las líneas es
muy sencillo y muy fácil de hacer ahora
bien qué pasa si nosotros no tenemos una
línea recta por ejemplo qué tal que
tenemos la gráfica de la función
la equis cuadrada déjenme déjenme hacer
otros ejes
aunque hay digamos oops
no parecía eje
digamos más o menos este es un eje
coordinado y este es otro eje coordinado
por favor
minimicen el hecho de que no están
derechitos pero bueno si yo tengo la
función de igual a x cuadrada ya la
conoces muy bien es una especie de
parábola que abre de esta forma más o
menos verdad entonces en realidad que
significaría calcular la pendiente en
una curva verdad porque si te das cuenta
la pendiente no no es la misma en todos
los puntos por ejemplo aquí en realidad
es es nula verdad estamos paralelos aquí
en este punto estamos paralelos al eje x
y sin embargo la pendiente va aumentando
va aumentando y se va volviendo más
pronunciado a medida que nos vamos
alejando en la dirección x ahora bien
entonces si tenemos un punto digamos
aquí digamos podemos más o menos ver que
la pendiente es igual a la de la recta
tangente
a una recta tangente que pasa por ese
punto entonces la pendiente está
asociada en una curva con la pendiente
de la recta tangente muy bien sin
embargo esta recta tangente no es la
misma por ejemplo si nos vamos ahora del
otro lado en realidad ahora tenemos una
recta tangente que más o menos hace esto
pero su pendiente es negativa entonces
no tenemos una pendiente igual a lo
largo de toda la curva para las líneas y
pasa no importaba qué puntos nos
tomábamos siempre era la misma pendiente
aquí no en las curvas depende de qué
punto estamos localizados y la pendiente
se calcula como la pendiente de esta
línea que es tangente en ese punto en
particular de la recta muy bien entonces
la pregunta que nos queda es como la
calculamos y aquí es en donde entran las
derivadas y como el concepto del límite
de una función es muy útil así que para
ejemplificar mucho mejor esto voy a
hacer nuevamente otros ejes
vamos a hacer esto un poquito más grande
hoy voy a tratar de hacer unos ejes muy
muy derechitos aunque ya me falló casi
al final
y vamos a hacer este otro eje muy bien
ahí tenemos nuestros ejes y voy a
dibujar digamos esta parábola un poquito
más grande
de esta forma okay digamos que es como
un acercamiento sale entonces nos nos
tomamos un punto cualquiera sobre la
recta digamos este punto aquí que
corresponde a algún punto a nx que y ahí
está nuestro punto a y que en el eje que
corresponde pues a la imagen de nuestro
punto a es decir f ok esta es la gráfica
es la gráfica de la función
f ahora bien qué pasa si nos tomamos un
puntito más alejado de estar digamos
aquí a más cierto número sí si nos
movemos hacia la gráfica aquí estará
este el punto correspondiente a amas h
verdad que simplemente es la imagen de a
más h
es decir aplicarle la función a más h
entonces una primera aproximación que
podemos hacer es aproximar la recta
tangente con una recta secante es decir
una recta que conecte a estos dos puntos
y por lo tanto es secante no es tan
gente a la curva muy bien entonces si
nosotros aproximamos de esta forma
podemos calcular en principio la
pendiente de esta recta fíjense que este
punto de aquí es el que tienen
coordenadas x a más h y en su coordenada
y es f
aplicado a más h muy bien este punto de
aquí tiene coordenadas a coma
fd a entonces podemos calcular la
pendiente de la recta que pasa por esos
dos puntos verdad simplemente tenemos
que considerar este restamos las las
coordenadas de jay y tenemos
efe de hamás h le restamos la coordenada
jet del otro punto que es f y luego todo
esto hay que dividirlo todo esto hay que
dividirlo entre la resta de las
coordenadas de x que es a más h - la
coordenada de este punto que está
entonces a menos a en realidad se
cancelan y éstos no pintan
verdad esto es en realidad no deben
aparecer y esto es la pendiente de la
recta secante cuando nos movemos h
unidades de nuestro punto que nos
interesa que es el punto a ok entonces
si queremos aproximar la pendiente de la
recta tangente tenemos que hacer que
esté a más h se parezca cada vez más a
nuestro punto a y eso es hacer h muy muy
muy pero muy chiquito verdad entonces la
pendiente de la recta tangente será la
misma que esto cuando la h se hace muy
pequeña es decir en términos de límites
y aquí es en donde entra la definición
del límite
queremos calcular el límite de esta
expresión cuando h tiende a cero cuando
h se hace muy pequeño muy pero muy
pequeño y esto de aquí
esto de aquí es justo la definición de
la derivada de nuestra función
efe en el punto a muy bien entonces si
realmente esto ejemplifica lo que es la
pendiente de la recta tangente ahora con
esto ya podemos calcular muchas
pendientes de muchísimas curvas que ya
no necesariamente tienen que ser líneas
ahora que ya tienes esta definición de
derivada voy a usarla para aplicarla en
funciones digamos como puede ser x
cuadrada x ala algo o sumas de funciones
que son muchísimas otras y vamos a hacer
varios ejercicios después así que nos
vemos en el próximo vídeo